اذا كثير من التطورات بالفعل يعني
استهدافات ل او قصف بالمدفعيه لمارون
الراس عيترون ميس الجبل ايضا استهداف موقع
لحزب الله في كفركلا و وايضا غاره على
الغندور هل من تفاصيل اضافيه وايضا ما اذا
كانت اتضحت الاضرار التي جاءت نتيجه
استهداف موقع لحزب الله في
كفركلا في الواقع كل هذه الامور والتفاصيل
تبدو صغيره امام المعادله الاكبر التي تم
رسمها اليوم من خلال اعلان حزب الله رسميا
عن
استهدافه قياده المنطقه الشماليه
الاسرائيليه في صفد ان تصل المسيرات
الانقضاض وفق البيان الذي اعلنه حزب الله
وايضا وفق ما تحدثت عنه الزميله جيفارا
واكدت بان اسرائيل اعلنت عن وصول هذه
المسيره الانقضاض الى تلك النقطه المتقدمه
في العمق الاسرائيلي فاننا ازاء محاوله
جديده من حزب الله لاعاده ترميم كل قواعد
الاشتباك التي خرقتها اسرائيل اكثر من مره
لا سما من خلال اغتيال القيادي في حركه
حماس صالح العاروري في قلب ضاحيه بيروت
الجنوبيه وبالامس استهداف احد ابرز القاض
العسكريين والميداني للحزب وسام طويل
والذي من المتوقع ان
يتم تنظيم جنازه تشيعه هنا في خربه سلم
حيث اتواجد تحديدا في هذه المنطقه هنا ضمن
هذا المربع عمليا اعلان حزب الله عن
استهدافه صفد وتلك القاعده العسكريه
باهميتها كونها القاعده التي تنظم كامل
القياده الشماليه لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وان تصل المسيرات وهذا
الاستهداف الى عمق يتجاوز 20 كم نحن نتحدث
عن اكثر من ذلك لربما تصل ال العمق الى 25
كم فان هذا الامر يعني بان حزب الله اختار
ان يرد بشكل سريع على على عمليه استهداف
واغتيال احد ابرز قادته العسكريين وقد ربط
في بيانه بان اطلاق هذه المسيرات وهذه
الهجمات باتجاه صفد وتحديدا مقر قياده
العمليات والقياده العسكريه ل لقوات
الاحتلال في
شمال الاراضي المحتله كل هذا الامر يعني
باننا ازاء فصل جديد من هذه المواجهه التي
باتت تتفلت من كل الضوابط خلال الايام الع
الماضيه نحن نتحدث عبد السلام عن تطورات
متسارعه عن امور مختلفه نتحدث عن معايير
جديده ترتبط بكيفيه تنظيم هذا الرد من قبل
حزب الله عندما قامت اسرائيل باغتيال صالح
العاروري في عمق ضاحيه بيروت الجنوبيه جرى
الحديث عن خرق لكل الخطوط الحمراء التي
كانت مرسومه والتي كان يسير على هذها تسير
على هذها المواجهات هنا عند الخط الجنوبي
للبنان وذلك منذ الثامن من اكتوبر تاريخ
بدء العمليات العسكريه جاء اغتيال صالح
العاروري واستشهاد صالح العاروري في قلب
ضاحيه بيروت الجنوبيه كي يغير كليا من من
المشهد هنا في جنوب لبنان استكمل الامر من
خلال هذا الاستهداف والاغتيال المباشر
الذي نفذته قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لا
لاحد ابرز القاض العسكريين والميداني لحزب
الله يوم امس وسام الطويل من خلال
استهدافه هنا في بلده خربه سلم حيث اتواجد
حاليا وبالتالي الرد الذي قام به حزب الله
اليوم ياتي ويندرج ضمن اطار هذا التوسيع
لدائره الردود والردود المضاده التي بتنا
بتنا نشاهدها
ونرصد بشكل مباشر الذي يمكن الحديث عنه
الان ان وصول الطائرات الانقضاض الهجوميه
وفق بيان حزب الله الى تلك النقطه
المتقدمه عمليا هو ياتي في محاوله رد واضح
وفق البيان ل عمليتي اغتيال صالح العاروري
ووسام الطويل ولكن ماذا يعني هذا الامر
نحن اذاء تطورات متسارعه على هذا الخط
الحدودي من الواضح ان كل عمليات الاحتواء
التي جرت خلال الفتره الماضيه سواء من
خلال الرسائل الغربيه او حركه الموفدين
الغربيين واخرهم وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
التي وصلت الى بيروت والمفترض ان تلتقي
خلال الساعات المقبله ابرز المسؤولين
اللبنانيين وايضا زياره جوزيف بوريل
والحركه التي تقوم بها الاداره الامريكيه
من خلال مفاد هوكست وايضا وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي كل هذه الخطوات وكل هذه الرسائل
التي وصلت الى بيروت كانت تاتي معها
بمواجهات
استهداف اسرائيلي تكسر كل القواعد نحن لم
نعد نتحدث عن قواعد اشتباك منذ الثامن من
اكتوبر بل نتحدث عن متغيرات يوميه ضمن
معادله كبيره وصلت فيها الحدود اللبنانيه
الى حافه الحرب ولكنها باتت تعمل ضمن اطار
مضبوط وايقاع مضبوط للمعارك اليوميه ولكن
هذه التطورات خلال الفت الفتره الماضيه
هذه عمليه الاغتيال تحويل لبنان مجددا الى
ساحه للاغتيالات وفق ما يقول مقربون من
حزب الله وايضا وفق ما تقول السلطات
الرسميه اللبنانيه كل هذا الامر هو يسعى
الى جر لبنان الى مربع مختلف جره الى
الحرب هذا الكلام قاله بالفم الان رئيس
حكومه تصيف الاعمال نجيب مقاطي الذي قال
بان عمليه الاغتيال اغتيال صالح العاروري
كانت تهدف الى تصدير ازمه نتنياهو من غزه
ومن الداخل الاسرائيلي باتجاه لبنان وا
ايضا اشار الى ان هذه الاغتيالات هي تسعى
الى نقل لبنان الى مربع اخر بمعنى فتح
المعركه بشكل كبير اليوم او بالامس عندما
جاء جاءت عمليه الاغتيال ايضا ضمن هذا
السياق افقنا اليوم على تنفيذ المسيرات
الاسرائيليه استهدافا مباشرا في بلده
الغندوري لسياره اطلقت باتجاهها صاروخين
وتم ووفق الدفاع المدني هنا في جنوب لبنان
استشهد ثلاثه اشخاص كانوا ضمن الس سياره
وعندما وصلت فرق الاسعاف لمحاوله انتشال
الجثامين تم اطلاق صاروخ ثالث من قبل
المسيره باتجاه فرق الاسعاف قبل ان تتمكن
من سحب الجثامين وبالتالي ضمن هذا
الاستهداف المفتوح الاسرائيلي الذي لم يعد
يقتصر عند الخط الحدودي ما نشهده نحن
فعليا منذ ايام عشره بان الغارات
الاسرائيليه سواء كانت من المقاتلات
الحربيه من المسيرات او حتى القصف المدفعي
بات تطال
عمقا مساحه جغرافيه في عمق الجنوب
اللبناني وبالتالي اليوم هذا الرد من حزب
الله يفتح المواجهه على مصرعيها الوصول
الى صفد يطرح سؤال هل ستنتهي الامور عند
هذا الحد ام انها مرشحه الى مزيد من
التصعيد هذا ما سنرصد خلال الساعه المقبله
وايضا ما سنرصد من خلال من خلال الكلام
الذي سي